everybody knew Game of Thrones I've been
getting a lot of requests for a night
King video like what is he capable of
what is he doing on the show how is he
different from the books so this will be
a video sort of differentiating the way
the TV shows using him powers and
abilities as well as what's going on
with him in the books because obviously
they're very different and they're a
little more mysterious about the way
they're using them on the TV show but
what will happen later tonight is I'll
post my episode 6 video and there's some
really good news about Game of Thrones
Season 8 that I'll talk about at the end
of this there's a lot of crazy stuff
that's been happening lately but there
might actually be some genuine good news
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get everything but just
to start with the night king of the TV
show from what we've seen so far he's
sort of like this ethereal bad guy this
sort of gives off this atmospheric bad
we've never heard him speak even though
we know that the others as they're
called in the books have a language it's
called Schroth it sounds like ice
cracking but since that big reveal in
season 4 about how the night Kean
created new White Walkers from Craster's
Suns he sort of been marching them
around in circles picking up people as
they go along stopping briefly for
episodes like hardhome to grab a whole
bunch of people at once we know that Dan
and Dave met with George our Martin a
couple years ago to sort of get a
roadmap for the series even though in
later seasons they've had a diverge a
lot from the books they got a lot of big
explainers from him so in season 6 when
we saw the children of the forest create
the night king that is a book plot point
it is the books are going to treat it a
slightly different way George RR
Martin's always like aha wait till you
see how I handle all of these things so
while he might not have all of the exact
same powers of greensight that they do
and power over nature he has most of the
same abilities power over nature power
to bring the winter with him is just one
of those big things that we've seen on
the TV show so far so I always get a lot
of questions about what does he want
what his ultimate goal and it sounds
like it's mostly just wiping the board
clean he's sort of like this mindless
person and it remains to be seen
whether or not the show will ever turn
him into an actual character because
right now he's sort of like a props that
they just wheel out he doesn't have any
dialogue you don't really know anything
about his motivation other than he just
wants to kill everybody we can start
spinning theories after the finale but I
think that this has caused them to
change their plans for season eight just
a little bit in the way they treat the
white walkers as a villain on the show
in favor of more human villains like
Cersei for instance so Cersei get the
big book upgrade just because they
painted themselves into a bit of a
corner with the white walkers as they
presented them so far so don't feel bad
if you're a little bit confused about
why they used him to market season seven
so much his face was like the face of
the first big poster they released like
holy [ __ ] he's coming but you don't see
him that much and there's a whole bunch
of twists that don't totally make sense
so at least on the TV show it feels like
there's a big question mark in front of
his face when it comes to what his
powers are what his story is going to be
it's a little more spelled out in the
books I know a lot of you are wondering
about the theory that he might be a
version of bran like all of the brand's
theory I talked a little bit about that
earlier this season I think it's taking
brands powers a little too far but I
certainly believe that it's possible
that he was a stark of Winterfell it's
just that when old man is telling her
tales back during the first book she
suggests to bran as she's telling this
story whose name is Brandon does the
mythical night's king the one that was
the 13th Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch was a brother of the king of
winters the stark King and Winterfell at
the time and his name was Brandon so I
think one she's trying to freak him out
and tell a really good story but I do
think that there's an element of truth
to that just like a lot of the
prophecies like you hear Melisandre talk
about how prophecy can be a tricky thing
there's elements of truth in there but
it's not meant to be literal truth so a
lot of people picked up on that and just
thought well you know if man is saying
that his name was Brandon then maybe
brand using his greenside powers going
into the past had something to do with
his creation as well but I don't think
the TV show night King is our brand I
think the TV show is doing a Cliff's
Notes version of the night king and when
George R Martin explains what old man
was talking about the night's king is
that the person on the TV show everyone
was asking that after we
learned about him in season six Martin
clarified that that person that old man
was talking about is no more alive today
than any of the other mythic people from
the Age of Heroes from thousands of
years ago so he definitely existed
because we know the long night happened
so there was a night's king at that time
but it makes it sound like cycle of Ice
and Fire you can kill the night's king
but you can also create another one so
at least in the books it sounds like
what happened is is that after the last
one was killed another one was raised up
and then started creating more White
Walkers
because Craster's son being turned into
White Walkers is a very big thing in the
books too we've seen several White
Walkers get killed up on the TV show but
how many sons did Craster have and we
have to imagine that there are probably
other people in the North that are doing
that too that have that pact with the
White Walkers we'll leave you alone as
long as you sacrifice us your male sons
so that we can create more White Walkers
the whole brand secret identity thing I
think just is risen up from the idea of
secret Targaryens there's that funny
saying that you're not really a
character on Game of Thrones
until you might secretly be someone else
in George R Martin is just really fond
of using the same name over and over so
like Aegon the Conqueror was such a
famous person that they were probably a
lot of Targaryens who name their sons
Aegon especially in the extended family
so it's the same thing with Brandon in
the stark family it's just a very common
name so it gets used over and over but
that doesn't mean that our brand is
somehow all of those brands but I do
think it's a really fun idea and I am
holding out hope that brand is sort of
like the opposite of the night King
because his powers flow from greensight
the same power to the children of the
forest so does the knight King so at
some point those two forces are going to
have to clash directly but we can talk
more about that after episode 6 because
I think there's still a couple big
twists to happen this season but it is
safe to say that the Knights kings of
the book the multiple ones however many
there have been have the same powers as
the ones that we've seen on the TV show
just in the way that the TV show is
jumping forward so fast I'm not
expecting to get too many supernatural
explainers so I think that's actually a
good thing because one that just lets us
have a little bit more fun with the
fandom like just kind of picking over it
trying to figure it out ourselves
but - it also leaves the door open for
George R Martin to do something slightly
different with it in
future books but we can glean that he
has powers of mass resurrection so while
a single white Walker can raise people
one at a time from the dead
the knight King can do an entire army
all at the same time I think it's mostly
just a proximity situation like all
these people along the beach at hardhome
here he was able to raise them all up so
we can say he has at least a
quarter-mile radius for his powers of
raising people from the dead but I think
it's a sliding scale of difficulty we've
only seen him raise humans before so I
don't think that he could just walk
south of the wall and go into like a zoo
and just raise everything from a
quarter-mile away I think just like
brand has an easier time controlling
small animals than controlling people
like Hodor with really powerful Minds
it's the same thing for the knight King
the more powerful the mind the closer
you have to be in the more focused you
have to be we've seen him create ice
weapons there's that ice blade that he's
been carrying around for the past couple
of seasons we know that he has the same
psychic greensight that bran has because
he sort of grabs him here so we know
that he does have a mind of his own he
has intelligence he has thoughts it's
just that we don't know what they are so
I do sympathize with you if you're
really upset that they haven't explored
his character more fully but I think
they just done that on the TV show in
favor of the more human characters like
they really want Cersei to be this
really big villain and it really seems
like they're using the night king is
more of the makeup and like oh we got
this thing off in the distance here it's
coming it's going to be really dangerous
but really most of the action that
they've dedicated themselves to is the
human drama like the back and forth of
the characters like what's going on with
Cersei in King's Landing what is she
going to do to throw things off the
rails what's going on between Jonathan
Ayers with them coming together what's
going on in Winterfell
there's a whole bunch of things that
we'll talk about after episode six
because a lot of people wondering is
ghosts going to come back so the TV show
is just making a lot of moves before
season 8 so the good news actually I'll
say now the good news about season 8 is
that they start shooting in October
which if you didn't know was around the
time that they started shooting last
year so earlier this year I did a video
about season 8 about how they basically
said that we might not get this till
2019 so everybody's shaking their fist
like you'd expect I mean of course it'd
be disappointing to go a whole year with
Game of Thrones we waited so long for
season seven but then a little while
after the season started it was reported
by HBO themselves that all of the season
8 scripts all six of them had been
submitted they're finished and they were
just figuring out how they were going to
film the season and that was the
potential big sources of delay but then
Nikolaj coster-waldau recently just said
that he was going back to Belfast to
start filming season 8 in October
meaning that they have their start date
so even if it still takes them about six
months to film the season which is a
normal shooting schedule for Game of
Thrones in a couple more months of post
after that there's a chance we can still
get those season 8 episodes by the
summer which i think is a best-case
scenario because they've also said that
they're going to wait till the year
after season 8 to premiere whatever the
prequel series is going to be they still
haven't revealed that they just did it
it's a very recognizable past event so
let me know in the comments what do you
think of the TV shows treatment of the
night king and what do you think they're
going to do with him in season 8 because
it sounds like they might defeat him
relatively quickly and then dream of
spring Lord of the Rings style the last
couple of episodes will just be
everybody trying to rebuild you'll
actually see some of that play out but
what'll happen is is I'll post my
episode 6 video tonight after the
episode airs we'll talk about all the
big crazy twists there is a new round to
that HBO now giveaway all you have to do
to enter just be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so while you wait
for everything you can click here for my
episode 6 video I'll update the link
when I post that video and you can click
here to learn all about Jon Snow's
father thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight